businesses in downtown las vegas
experience a boom in foot traffic this
comes as really great news to many local
shops that have struggled so much
throughout the past year
kate houston live downtown right at main
street in california
kate as we can see and you showed us
it's been packed out there all day
yes there's definitely signs of normalcy
and vibrancy here in the downtown las
vegas arts district
right behind me here you can see all of
these parking spots are
filled and it's really been like that
all day with both locals and visitors
taking time to shop and support these
local businesses
makers and finder says they've had a
huge surge in business over the past few
weeks
this morning there was a 20 person wait
list which is a lot for the weekday
crowd
down the street rebar is now open seven
days a week
they say their numbers are reaching
pre-pandemic levels
maybe higher both businesses say this
could be due to a combination of reasons
more people are getting vaccinated
there's nice weather
and the revitalization efforts of the
city and local businesses are paying off
during the pandemic there's literally 10
new
bars restaurants breweries that opened
while everything was closed and shut
down construction never stopped
i think there's a huge draw here right
now you know a lot of the new signs they
planted these trees recently which was
really cool
um so there's something appealing about
it not just the storefronts but
everyone's efforts i think are being
recognized
now businesses in downtown are gearing
up for the first in person
first friday in more than a year on
april 2nd
makers and finders is installing a new
garage door and planning live music in
the near future
rebar is expecting quite the crowd
saying it will be a test in
occupancy levels back out here live
businesses say downtown las vegas
has come a long way over the past few
years
at six i'm going to show you the new
project launched by the city
to encourage people to come visit the
downtown area
for now reporting live near california
and main street kate houston 8 news now